in 1704 using a series of calculations
isaac newton predicted the world would
end sometime around the year 2060.
almost 300 years later in 1973 a
computer at mit made the prediction that
life as we know it will end around the
year 2040. it also predicted that some
of the first signs would be seen in the
year 2020. some of its predictions have
come true and scientists are taking this
seriously let's find out why
in the 300 years since isaac newton's
ominous prediction there have been
plenty of doomsayers announcing the end
of the world usually these folks are
religious zealots false prophets frauds
or all the above but in the 1970s
computer scientists said hold my beer
their scientific predictions aren't
based on ancient texts or interpretation
of scripture instead they use data
models computer scientists have come to
the same apocalyptic conclusion as
newton right down to the date now to be
clear the end of the world in this
context doesn't mean the end of the
planet or even the end of life on the
planet it just means the collapse of
society the model is based on the work
of jay wright forester who's considered
the father of system dynamics which is
well system dynamics is a methodology
and mathematical modeling technique used
to understand complex issues and
problems oh thanks very helpful okay a
little less slogany systems are pretty
much everything system dynamics is how
pieces of the system relate to each
other for example the deer population is
a system the resulting calculation using
system dynamics is called a stock the
number of dearborn is a dynamic piece of
that data that adds to the population
the number of deer that die subtracts
from the population okay but to that
model we start adding more and more
complexities like the birth rate of the
deer which takes into account how many
deer there are what percentage of those
deer are female and what percentage of
those are likely to have offspring we
calculate their death rate by knowing
how many deer there are and what is
their average lifespan now that's a
simple way to calculate deer population
but you can do all kinds of complexities
to this model like
is hunting affecting the population and
if so what percentage of deer are killed
how often are deer killed in accidents
do weather conditions affect the
population what about local food sources
or what kinds of predators are present
you then fine tune all these different
input variables and if your model is
accurate you can get pretty good results
now mit researchers developed the
program which they called world 3 to
simulate global sustainability and it
was built using system dynamics the
study looked at the five factors thought
most likely to affect growth on earth
population increase agricultural
production non-renewable resource
depletion industrial output and
pollution generation the scientists who
participated in this research were
excited to see a bright future in the
results instead the program predicted
the end of the world
[Music]
to predict what the future of worldwide
growth looks like given finite planetary
resources the mit researchers who
developed the doomsday model were
commissioned by an elite organization
called the club of rome the club of rome
sounds like an illuminati group oh yeah
there are plenty of fun conspiracies
about these guys no can we
well that's not really the point of this
video please
please please please please fine fine
fine fine fine thank you the club of
rome was created in 1968 by the
morganthou group during a secret meeting
at rockefeller's private estate bellagio
yeah this sounds right the meeting was
organized by aurelio pache an italian
industrialist who had close ties to the
alavetti corporation and fiat now pache
claimed to have solutions for world
peace and prosperity which could be
accomplished through a new world order
there it is the club of rome was
established with 75 prominent
industrialists economists and scientists
from 25 nations the bilderberg group and
the club of rome are the most important
foreign policy arms of the round table
which is led by the committee of 300.
roundtable committee 300. well the round
table is a secret society that if you
believe the theory is building the new
world order no i believe it i know you
do the committee of 300 is a council
that creates policy for groups like the
club of rome and the trilateral
commission trilateral commission yeah
it's a rabbit hole each of these groups
deserves its own video back to the club
of rome and the mit experiment the club
of rome acts as a research institute on
political social and economic issues and
supposedly nato economic and military
policy comes directly from this group
the club of rome claims that the future
survival of mankind depends on a new
global community under a single form of
government new world order right and the
biggest threat to this new world order
and the biggest threat to mankind is
overpopulation now it's been alleged
that the club of rome supports massive
depopulation using any means necessary
any means any means in august 1980
howard odom who was a member of the club
of rome was quoted saying it's necessary
that the u.s cut its population by
two-thirds within the next 50 years
now he failed to mention how this would
be accomplished so that's when the club
of rome found unlikely but effective
partners for scientists from mit
[Music]
the mit computer program was designed to
look at the current projected trends
around pollution natural resources
consumption and population growth and
see what would happen the results were
published by the club of rome in a book
called the limits to growth released in
1973. a some immediately criticized the
data being inaccurate but supporters
claimed this was western society
avoiding responsibility the program's
results show that once all factors
converge quality of life will quickly
decline ultimately leading to collapse
of society and this convergence was
predicted to occur in 2020.
2020 was a rough year yeah you ain't
just whistling dixie according to the
club of rome's report the collapse can
only be prevented if nations like the
usa and china stop devouring global
resources you're not gonna stop buddy
they're not but carbon emissions in the
us are actually going down and even
china claims their carbon emissions are
down slightly from a year or two ago
fake news probably but what the limits
to growth model failed to predict is the
explosion of growth in emerging
countries india pakistan indonesia the
philippines north korea peru sri lanka
ukraine carbon emissions are up between
5 and 20 in those countries and over 2
billion people live there that's a
quarter of the world's population now
those economies are not going to slow
down anytime soon and their carbon
emissions are only going up so clearly
at least according to this model we're
still at risk
okay some perspective
is climate change and overpopulation
dangerous
i don't know there's debate on this and
i don't know who's right
you don't either these debates are so
full of noise and emotion that it's hard
to know who to trust now instinctively i
would trust scientists from mit about
just about anything and i think that was
intentional the club of rome already had
come to the conclusion that there is a
threat of imminent global collapse they
arrived at this conclusion before hiring
the scientists at mit who coincidentally
came up with this exact conclusion that
fits the agenda so can we trust this
research i don't think so
i don't either for a long time tobacco
companies paid scientists to publish
misleading information the most famous
of these was called a frank's statement
to cigarette smokers which was published
in over 400 newspapers in 1954 and the
study said there is no proof that
cigarette smoking causes lung cancer
tens of thousands of doctors general
practitioners surgeons specialists
doctors in every branch of medicine were
included and according to this
nationwide survey more doctors smoke
camels than any other cigarette
yeah boy in 1981 a japanese study proved
the dangerous effects of secondhand
smoke again big tobacco bought
themselves some science that said
otherwise in the 90s they sponsored
studies saying that dirty air filters
were more dangerous to the lungs than
cigarettes come on and in the 60s sugar
companies paid scientists at harvard to
report that sugar doesn't make you fat
and doesn't have a role in heart disease
and as recently as 2017 coca-cola and
the mars candy company funded research
to divert attention away from their
products connected to obesity and
diabetes the fact is
70 of all scientific research is funded
by private companies and that money
often comes with strings of the most
recent 50 food industry sponsored
studies 70 of them yielded results that
were favorable to the sponsor
25 of them were neutral and less than
five percent of the studies came to
conclusions that did not favor the
sponsor's product consider the messenger
that's right
we're constantly bombarded by scientific
studies on everything which ones can we
trust none of them
none of them now the next time the media
throws data at you that they got from a
scientific paper take a minute to look
at who paid for the research more often
than not there's an agenda unfortunately
most people including the media won't
take the time to find out who benefits
i think that's the point
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
subscribe like comment share all that
stuff
really helps the channel until next time
be safe be kind know that you are
appreciated
do
[Music]